- [Instructor] In which picture is the cow
beside the little chicken
here, the little chick?
Choose one answer.
So which one do you think it is?
Well, over here, they
aren't beside each other.
Over here, they are.
So I would pick choice B.
Let's do another example.
Which elephant is behind the bricks?
Think about it.
Which one is behind the bricks, A or B?
Well, in choice A, the elephant
is in front of the bricks.
It's in choice B that the elephant
it looks like it's
hiding behind the bricks
just sneaking around.
Alright, I'm gonna go with choice B.
Let's do one more example.
Which shape is below this
green rectangle over here?
So if I look over here,
this is our green rectangle
and which one is below it?
Well, we see this red triangle.
So this is below the green
triangle and we are done.